in the last video I spoke a bunch about
the determining factor on whether we
have inflation or deflation it isn't so
much the money supply although the money
supply will have an effect it's really
capacity utilization capacity
utilization is driven by demand and I
made that distinction because you know I
gave that example of the island where
you could have a very small money supply
for example one seashell but if the
velocity is really high then people are
expressing that demand and you'll have
very high utilization of all of the
capacity in the island and you might
have inflation even though the money
supply is one seashell on the other hand
let's say we found a bunch of seashells
but everyone stops transacting so the
velocity were to slow down a bunch so in
that case even though the money supply
is huge or you know a lot larger than it
was people aren't expressing demand so
demand will be a lot lower than capacity
as we showed in the cupcakes economics
video when you have high or a lot of
unused capacity it's everyone's
incentive to kind of try to sell that
extra unit and they all lower prices so
you could have an increased money supply
but if the velocity slows down or if
demand is slowing down because that's
what's causing the de philosophie
slowdown then you could still have a
deflationary situation so given all of
that that we talked about and actually I
you know we touched on this chart where
we showed that every inflationary major
inflationary bout was actually was
actually stimulated or is actually
preceded by a pretty big upturn in
capacity utilization and the inflation
really started going once capacity
utilization got into the 80% range and
you could imagine that on average that's
when if on average the world is running
at 80% that means that some people are
running at 70 some people are running at
90 95 percent and those people who are
running at 95 percent those are the
people who say gee instead of trying to
run at 96 97 98 percent utilization why
don't I just raise price and not having
to worry about producing that extra unit
and obviously their inputs go into other
people's their outputs go to other
people's inputs and then it you get a
generalized price inflation now with
that said actually I want to make
another point in nineteen in the early
70s all the way everyone always talks
about the oil shock right in 1973 and
the Yom Kippur War
we resupplied Israel and then I had all
the OPEC countries that essentially
stopped selling oil to the US and a lot
of other Western nations and people say
you know oil prices shot through the
roof and that's what drove inflation
that supply shock that probably
contributed to it but 1973 just CF is
right around is right around there so if
you actually look at this chart we're
already kind of on an inflationary
spectrum prices the generalized prices
were already increasing and capacity
utilization had really preceded that
that probably just added fuel to the
flame
well that said everybody know the
question that everyone's wondering about
is what's going to happen now so before
the current financial crisis let me just
we had a certain amount of capacity we
had actually let me say that let's say
this is everything this is the u.s.
output u.s. output and in a normal
environment in the nor let say this is
u.s. GDP right output it GDP is just
output so in a normal developed
environment so if you go back into the
60s and I should probably draw get the
Bloomberg chart on this too because it's
pretty interesting we spent about we
consumed about 60% of our sixty sixty
percent of our GDP was on consumption
and consumption always isn't a bad thing
let me turn off my phone
three consumption isn't always a bad
thing it's actually what we use to have
a good standard of living you know if I
have a nice sofa a TV set and I go on
vacations that's consumption but it
improves our standard of living and the
goal of all countries is really to
improve that average standard of living
but the remainder is savings the
remainder in a traditionally you know
kind of responsible developed nation you
save 40 percent maybe 30 to 40 percent
depending on your whether you're Japan
or whether you're Western Europe and
what savings turns into is essentially a
new investment to raise your output so
this savings is what allows you to
increase your output in the next year
whoops my screen so if you don't do that
savings your output if you don't if you
don't save even a little bit your output
will actually decrease because you
you're no one will invest in factories
and the factories will get old and the
roads will stop you know being usable
and all the rest whenever investment
whenever someone's investing that's
someone else's savings and it's very
important to realize that their
investment and savings are really two
sides of the same coin if no one's
saving then there's no money for
investment but just going back to this
example when people are saving that's
what not only maintains output but
actually increases total output so this
would be in you know the next year or
the next decade and then when we consume
sixty percent of this we're consuming a
sixty percent of a larger number and our
standard of living will go up and this
is a very sustainable and good situation
what happened unfortunately over the
really since since the early 80s is that
we had a constant expansion of credit
and we started lending more and more
money to to everyone and other countries
started lending more and more money to
us and almost of that got expressed in
more and more consumption so if you look
at u.s. output u.s. output actually if
you this is GDP if you actually go to
2007 the average American we consumed
more than we produced we had a negative
saving so if I were to draw that if I
were to draw that it looks like this in
2007 consumption was larger than our
total output consumption so the question
is how did this happen well essentially
if you know let's put all you know
everyone talks about money in currencies
essentially we borrowed output from
other people when we borrow money from
the Chinese which we use to buy their
goods we're essentially just buying
their we're borrowing their output right
we're borrowing their Goods and when we
give them a dollar bill that's a promise
that in the future they could use that
dollar bill to come back and use some of
our output but over the course of the
last several decades we were just
borrowing other people's output and we
became net debtor so when your
consumption is actually larger than your
output you immediately start to realize
that this isn't a sustainable situation
for too long and maybe we borrowed a
little bit more money and actually did
turn out that way that we borrowed some
people's
output even more to fuel some of our
investment as well it's not like no
investment was going on for the last 20
30 years we had a lot of investment but
it was essentially being the consumption
and the investment was being financed by
other people's output and of course when
you have consumption kind of touching up
against you know your fully utilized
that makes even more incentive to invest
so all of these people were willing to
invest in the US what happened now is
you realize that a lot of this a lot of
the financing or a lot of the debt that
was being taken on it was you know it
was being facilitated by people homes
and home equity loans but people really
aren't good for it and now all of a
sudden the banks have dried up liquidity
is gone people can't borrow money and
you have a demand shock so what you have
is a situation where a considerable
amount of this consumption and actually
a good a considerable amount of that
investment that was being fueled by
financing disappears right and you know
now that we're in a global world we
really should think about global output
but it doesn't matter we could we could
talk about just u.s. output but now that
this demand has disappeared if this is
US output and let's say this is output
that you know we were taking it from
China or Japan or wherever else and our
consumption has now fallen down here and
it's not because all of a sudden people
became prudence because people aren't
willing to lend them to go to
williams-sonoma and buy a $50 spatula or
whatever else they just can't get
another credit card loan or a home
equity loan so you have the situation
now where you have low utilization and
this comes back and what we talked about
in the last video then when you have low
utilization it's everyone's incentive to
lower prices when you have a bunch of
vacant houses people lower rents when
the car factories are empty people lower
the price of car factories when people
are underutilized wages go down and this
is see this shock more recently right
here as we express we've said in the
last video the orange line is us
capacity utilization and it dropped from
let's see that was about the 80% range
and if it had gone up here I would have
I would have started getting worried
about hyperinflation but it you see
right around summer of 2007 it dropped
off of a cliff and it's down here
someplace
and as you see a little bit later
inflation dropped
so that dynamic that we've been talking
about capacity utilization falling off
because we essentially had a demand
shock and then that's led to a decrease
in prices so the question is everything
that the treasurer is doing and the Fed
is printing money and Obama is spending
a trillion dollar stimulus is that going
to lead to inflation my answer is just
watch the capacity utilization numbers
and just so you know you know the
stimulus plan the whole idea about is
they didn't want us the the government
doesn't want us to enter into a
deflationary spiral so if consumption
drops like this we have all of this
capacity and prices go down if prices go
down a little bit it doesn't affect
people's behavior in aggregate but if
people start having an expectation that
wages will go down that prices will go
down then they all go into panic mode
and they stop spending then prices and
utilization you know let's say they
stopped spending stop spending then
utilization goes down even more than
unemployment goes up even more and this
also and makes fear go up even more
unemployment going up and fear going up
makes people stop spending even more and
this is that deflationary cycle that all
the economists and all of the government
officials are afraid of and you saw that
in the during the Great Depression right
here let me draw a zero point to show
you where so if this is this is 0 that
is 0 let me draw it further that's the
the dividing line between inflation and
deflation and you see we've had a couple
of bouts of deflation and they normally
aren't good times in the world this is
the Great Depression right here this is
post-world War One and the Great
Depression actually lasted all the way
until so you entered the war and the
late 30 so it's right about here to here
we had a little bit of inflation kind of
yet the first wave of the New Deal
stimulating some spending but it really
never got us to any significant level of
inflation just so you have a sense I
would consider anything above 5 percent
inflation is kind of really really bad
and let me draw a line there so that's
kind of the 5 percent inflation mark you
see we really didn't get it 5 percent
above 5% inflation until you
with World War one and then you have the
post-war period we're under Bretton
Woods and then in the 70s we had thee as
I talked about before you know you get
the oil shock and all of the rest and
you know the rest is history but as you
see the deflationary periods were just
things that government officials want to
avoid altogether so the idea of the
stimulus is for the government to borrow
money because no one else can and they
can essentially take fill up the gap
where the consumer is left off now the
question is are they going to fill up
enough of a gap and actually I realize
that I'm running out of time again I
don't like to make these videos too long
so I'll talk about that in the next
video